Well, let's take a look at the forces acting on this car. Well, we know there's the normal force.
And we know there's gravity but we don't want to write that as a downwards arrow.
But rather as a perpendicular arrow and a parallel one.
And in the last video, we showed that the parallel force is equal to
the weight of the car in mg times the sin of α.
Now the steepest angle hill, well that occurs when friction force is totally maxed out.
When it is at exactly its maximum value, which is 80% of the car's weight
or put in another way Ff = 0.8 mg.
Well in this situation where the car is just barely holding on, we know the friction force
is balancing the parallel force so we can set these two equal to each other.
Notice something amazing that happens. The m's and g's, the whole weight cancels out.
This doesn't depend at all on the mass of your vehicle. Amazing!
Well now, I have to take the inverse sine of 0.8 to solve for the sin of α.
But still, I take this inverse sine of 0.8 and I get an answer of 53°.
I'm very impress if you're able to get this on your first try or even your second or third.